[MUSIC PLAYING]
ANKUR KOTWAL: So here we are
on the Code the Road bus,
and it's a really
exciting time for us
because it is the 10-year
anniversary of the Maps API.
We're going to be traveling
across the country
to hear about how the Google
Maps API has helped developers
to build great apps and
build their businesses on it.
ASHLEY SMITH: The road trip
is going to be really great.
We have a 1959 GM
bus that's going
to be driving from here
all the way to Disney.
We have some really
cool stops, 14.
We have one with
Harley Davidson.
We have one with Sesame Street.
We're all really excited
to go to these places.
It's a whole month long.
We have fun flamingos.
It's going to be a good time.
TRICIA DESJARDINS: We're here
at our first stop at I/O,
and the developer
feedback has been amazing.
MALE SPEAKER 1: Have any of
you used the Maps APIs before?
MALE SPEAKER 2: My [INAUDIBLE].
MALE SPEAKER 1: Oh, fantastic.
FLORIAN BERTELE: The
Code the Road bus
is like a rolling museum.
It houses a couple of really
cool demos of our partners
using the Maps API and
their applications.
MONICA HERMAN: One of the
great things about Google
is that it connects
people all over the world.
And our postcards are sort
of our retro throwback way
to show how we used
to do that before.
It's really been a
hit with everyone
that's come by the bus.
We've been really impressed to
see how many people actually
participated and sent postcards
to their families and friends.
ALL: Road trip!
TRICIA DESJARDINS:
Next stop, Logan.
MONICA HERMAN: Whoo!